gmail's what i'm on now that's the uh
you gotta have the most space for
attachments
anyway thank you feel free to hit me up
if you remember that number i noticed
you ain't write that down
damn damn damn that girl was fly right
shy
but did you see that liam nieces movie
with them wolves though
the one with them big ass wolves and
lamb nieces
oh liam neeson straight jacked up their
mouths
and walls and don't even get me started
on that one when they took his daughter
straight talking starring liam neeson's
man leave me this is on the phone like
i have a certain set of excuses
don't even try and be rushing around
liam neeson's he'll take your own
distractions
and then oh you see the second one and
the second one the russians come after
him
and he [ __ ] them all up anyway took in
two starring the incomparable
liam neesons that's my what about doc
man no no huh
what about liam nieces in some dark man
no what about
dark man when liam neesa's face was
changing
homie was straight face changing now
that's just liam nieces acting right
there
man straight up i kid you not academy
award caliber
classic nieces oh seriously i mean like
nieces already need to have a statue
leave me since ain't got no he ain't got
a statue he ain't got a statue he ain't
got a statue no
no no
the oscar goes too liam neeson's dark
man
face was changing how hard is that ain't
hard
it's not hard at all damn that's stupid
battleship
and oh [ __ ]
battle ship
[Applause]
battleship liam neeson straight killed a
robot
boat liam neeson is my shiz knit
but you know who i like as much as niece
sisters as much as nieces
who bruce willie
what if they made a movie with liam
neeson's hey i'm bruce willie
nieces and willie glee and nieces harder
man
harder fat wood